avoue gaspard peau elle est pas belle la
vie
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
soucieux de participer
à la liesse qui depuis mercredi envahi
toutes les ondes qui a fait se déplacer
la moitié des journalistes à l'autre
bout de la terre pour couvrir
l'événement we et dont les résultats
influencera de façon aussi considérable
nos vies que le calcul rénal de françois
fillon je joins ma joie au concert d'
enthousiasme vives jean ping nouveau
président si
[Musique]
béni soit tu gloire à toi cher leader
communiste qui chaque jour nous rappelle
que le capitalisme se porte aussi bien
sans démocratie que le socialisme se
porte mal sans manuel valls
merci aussi à ce beau pays de me fournir
cette anecdote charmante cette petite
fille de 4 ans défigurée par des
vêtements made in china
alors des vêtements qui ont été traitées
si fort contre les moisissures qui lui
ont causé une allergie très sévères sont
vraiment trop forts et chez moi il
arrive à creuser en même temps notre
balance commerciale et notre trou de la
sécu
culturellement alors c'est la semaine
des prix littéraires avec cette sortie
fracassante le bouquin que tout le monde
a lu le rapport sur la compétitivité
alors je les lui gelé luce ceux qui
proposent n'est pas très nouveau race et
les classiques quoi la réorientation de
l'industrie vers l'armement la création
d'une voiture du peuple s'ouvrir vers
l'espace vital à l'est
ah non pardon se confond avec un autre
truc
je confonds avec le rapport qui a permis
de lancer les trente glorieuses
pas le même style là c'est beaucoup là
comme c'est la mode en ce moment le
style du rapport sur la compétitivité
c'est plus de l'ordre du roman porno
économique quoique c'est un mélange de
christine angot et de jacques attali le
truc alors l'histoire ça raconte la
misère d'une nommé france dont le péché
mignon et de se faire très régulièrement
prendre en étau entre l'allemagne et les
pays à bas coûts peut-être le seul côté
novateur parce qu'il faut bien avouer
que dans youporn c'est très rare de
trouver la catégorie double pénétration
france chine allemagne
[Applaudissements]
l'auteur à certains gallois un homme qui
à lui seul résume le déclin français
enfin quand on a été patron de ads et
qu'on finit sa carrière en écrivant une
thèse sous la direction de jean-marc
ayrault à ce rythme là dans deux ans et
les animateurs à l'ucp à
international alors on m'a poussé il
faut en parler d'accord je vais en
parler de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
un fait divers assez anodin à un noir
réélu à la tête des usa c'est bon tout
le monde est content il est élu grâce au
vote féminin donc forcément c'était plus
une élection mais un concours de beauté
et c'est là c'était vite plié quoi entre
une future icône nespresso est un
mannequin pour séminaires au novotel
frei avait pas photo
alors pour le coup on connaît la plus
connue de ses électrices s'appelle sont
dit oui en amérique et les catastrophes
naturelles font les élections en europe
celle inverse les élections qui font les
catastrophes naturelles
quelle ferveur en europe pour obama
c'est vraiment on est vraiment attirés
que par ce qui nous ignorent c'est obama
je crois que la seule fois où il a
prononcé le mot europe durant sa
campagne c'est lorsqu'il a fait un
lapsus pour dire grèce
alors un journal a fait l'inventaire des
goûts culturels des deux candidats obama
et mme star trek et les fugees romney m
star wars sérieux robison au moins aux
usa les parents sont vite au courant de
l'avenir des gamins si les gosses scène
david lynch et tchaïkovski pas oublier
la politique
façon qu'est ce qu'on va retenir des
élections américaines barack est
toujours amoureux de michel et c'est
toujours dire bonjour son avion c'est un
steward quoi
autre chose à l'international
kim jong il est vivant il s'appelle psy
fait de la musique
il restera à jamais dans l'histoire
comme le père de cet incroyable pas de
danse qui consiste à imiter le chevauche
âge d'une prostituée avec l'aisance d'un
jockey formé par michou
gérard longuet le mime marceau
réactionnaire
adresser un très beau bras d'honneur à
l'idée de repentance algérienne alors
moi je comprends pas cette histoire de
repentance par rapport à l'algérie
française veut dire deux d'accord ok fin
on est partis tard de là bas mais n'est
ce pas la preuve qu'on était attaché
alors je ne dis pas que la france n'ait
pas commis d'erreur en algérie phare est
bien sûr bien sûr oublier de pomper tout
le pétrole avant les accords d'evian
quelle connerie
et il faut l'avouer c'est vrai qu entre
1952 et 1962 les services publics
français ont une manière un peu viril de
demander aux algériens certains
renseignements sur des amis éventuels
qui aurait pu être mêlé à des affaires
de feu d'artifice illégaux
la france ne s'est jamais excusé mais
l'algérie s'est elle excusée nous avoir
envoyé une rico macias
[Applaudissements]
sans transition selon serge dassault
l'homosexualité est une des raisons de
la décadence de la grèce c'est vrai il
ya trois raisons
l'at-on socrate aristote quel tas de
fumistes
comment admirer des gens qui passaient
leur journée à caresser des concepts
tout en chatouillant des effets pour
arrêter
quand même gonflé d'assaut quoi un
industriel de l'armement qui t'explique
que l'homosexualité c'est la fin du
monde la bombe atomique qui se moque du
gaz moutarde
quelques bonnes nouvelles quand même le
mariage gay est devenu le mariage pour
tous
enfin pouvoir officialiser avec ma mère
[Applaudissements]
le plus dur ça sera d'annoncer à mon
frère que c'est aussi mon fils
une bonne nouvelle pour nos amis sdf 52
morts par jour en france à cause des
accidents domestiques c'est bon arrêtez
de vous plaindre sur ce coup là vous
êtes à l'abri
alors
la belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus